[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on va continuer notre
série sur les criminels et on va
s'intéresser tout particulièrement à la
différence qu'il ya entre les
psychopathes d'un côté et des
sociopathes de l'autre qui sont ces
personnalités qui peuplent nos faits
divers nos films séries qui nourrissent
notre imaginaire collectif et qui suit
site une forme de curiosité malsaine
curiosité comme acquis sont caricaturés
dans les films dans les séries mais en
réalité ces individus existe également
dans notre société et il pourrait être
utile d'en connaître davantage sur est
ce que par exemple c'est un trouble
génétique ou est-ce que ça se déclenche
au cours de la vie de quelqu'un comme
psychopathe ou un sociopathe commet un
crime ça se traduit comment dans les
faits on va explorer ensemble leur
cerveau et on va voir ce qu'on y trouve
et pour être plus précis dans mon
travail de recherche j'ai contacté
quatre psychiatres sur internet
directement un seul d'entre eux a bien
voulu répondre à mes questions mais il y
a répondu brillamment je le remercie
vous allez découvrir ses réponses tout
au long de cette vidéo une autre petite
précision malgré le travail de
recherches intenses qu'on a pu faire
pour cette vidéo on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
pas de réel consensus qui a été établi
aujourd'hui pour dire un psychopathe
c'est ça un sociopathe c'est ça les
différences entre les deux c'est ça et
ça sinon ce serait pas une vidéo aussi
long que ça prendrait deux secondes ce
serait très facile donc tout ce que je
veux dire à prendre avec des pincettes
mais ça reste un faisceau d'indicés pour
mieux comprendre ces deux individus
maintenant que cela est dit loïc
généreux
[Musique]
loïc d'après toi qui sponsorise cette
vidéo aujourd'hui
exacte
non européennes qui célèbre ses 10 ans
s'est levé peine élu meilleur vpn de
tous les vpn lors des derniers best vpn
powers de 2019 et 2020 parce que oui il
ya des concours de vpn qui s'organisait
par vpn menteur et pc mag l'utilisation
de normes et pen est super simple pour
toutes les applications que vous avez
déjà utilisé un vpn ou pas leurs
serveurs sont extrêmement rapides vous
pouvez avoir jusqu'à six appareils
connectés sur le même compte vous pouvez
même l'utiliser en w pn si vous voulez
chiffres et le chiffrage du fouet le
truc mais ça sert à quoi notre peuple
est grand un petit pouce à surfer avec
plus de sécurité lorsque vous êtes sur
un wifi publics par exemple dans un bar
en voyage à la fac petit deux groupes
index a contourné légers aux
restrictions pour regarder des
programmes étrangers depuis la france ou
pour regarder des programmes français
depuis l'étranger et grands trois petits
doigts qu'on ne citera pas si un vpn
vous intéresse penser à nord vdn
pourquoi écoutez je vais vous le dire
fait plaisir lui vous aurez la garantie
de 30 jours satisfait ou remboursé vous
aurez un service clients en france et 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et surtout
et pour pas dire de bêtises je vais vous
le dire avec l'offrant courant passant
par mon lien en descriptions avec le
code fabien olicard vous allez profiter
d'une grande réduction à moi gratuit est
un cadeau spécial pour son anniversaire
noordpeene vous offre un mois
supplémentaire une année supplémentaire
ou deux années supplémentaires
d'abonnement gratuit ça c'est selon
votre chance et ça ça fait plaisir merci
marc bp allez on va commencer direct par
une faune fac pour vous plonger en plein
dedans james fallon un chercheur en
neurosciences de l'université de
californie a mené des investigations
pendant une vingtaine d'années pour
savoir si la psychopathie été le fruit
d'une malformation ou d'une anomalie
intérieur du cerveau pour ce faire il a
analysé des milliers des milliers de
scan de cerveau de meurtrier et de
cerveaux normaux et pour faire des
comparaisons ils utilisaient tous les
cerveaux qu'il avait à sa disposition
c'est à dire des scans de son propre
cerveau et de celui de ses proches il y
en a donc profité pour tous regardent et
en 2005 qui fait une découverte plus
qu'étonnante l'un des scans attire son
attention il constate une faible
activité sur les eaux ni à l'empathie à
la moralité et au contrôle de soi sont
des zones qui sont justement en lien
avec la psychopathie et ce cerveau qui
l'observent y découvre que c'est le sien
je vous laisse imaginer comment james
hallucine il a du mal à y croire il
remet même en question ses propres
recherches alors pour vérifier sa
théorie ils creusent un peu plus en
faisant des tests génétiques et on lui
découvre un potentiel agressif avec très
peu d'empathie effectivement une sorte
de variante d'un gène qui en effet
billets au comportement agressif
le chercheur a nommé avoir quelques
défauts esprit de compétition très
développés qui nuit parfois ses
relations il est parfois capable de
manipuler les gens qui l'entourent pour
atteindre ces objectifs il l'admet mais
de là à être un psychopathe tué et violé
des gens il ya quand même un fossé qui
franchira jamais alors comment expliquer
que ce père de famille qui prêtait pas
de doute aucune histoire peut avoir des
caractéristiques anatomiques similaire à
celle des personnes qui ont fait l'objet
de comportement ou de crime affreux pour
lui le fait d'avoir été aimée dans sa
famille c'est la protéger des conduites
à risque et des accès de violence etc on
peut donc considérer que la génétique
l'environnement et le libre arbitre sont
des facteurs qui cumulait joue un rôle
dans ce que va devenir ensuite la
personne du coup cette découverte ça
fait l'effet d'un déclic chez lui et il
a décidé d'accepter sa psychopathie en
disant qu'il s'agit d'un bon psychopathe
le bon psychopathe et le mauvais
psychopathe je cite une de ses
déclarations depuis que j'ai trouvé tout
cela j'ai fait un effort pour essayer de
changer mon comportement je pense plus
aux sentiments des autres alors
attention quand même faut savoir que
dans sa lignée familiale
il y as est meurtrier présumé dont
lizzie borden une femme qui a été accusé
d'avoir tué son père et sa belle-mère à
la hache voilà comme quoi tous ces
ancêtres n'ont pas eu la main vite lui
non plus alors après cette entrée en
matière un peu étonnante on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet qu'est ce qui
distingue vraiment les psychopathes et
les sociopathes je vous avais laissés
sur cette question dans le premier
épisode et c'est à ça qu'on va répondre
aujourd'hui ces deux types de
personnalité appartiennent à la même
catégorie les troubles de la
personnalité antisociale le docteur
donald budge blick explique que le
trouble de là finalité anti social se
traduit par un modèle de comportement
socialement irresponsable exploiteurs et
sans culpabilité les symptômes
comprennent donc le non respect de la
loi l'incapacité à conserver un emploi
stable par exemple la manipulation
d'autrui à des fins de gains personnels
la tromperie d'autrui et l'incapacité à
développer des relations
interpersonnelles stable ou s'est elle
même puis ce qu'ils appartiennent à la
même catégorie de troubles c'est pas
étonnant qu'il y ait autant de
caractéristiques communes entre les deux
en réalité qu'est ce qui les différencie
vraiment vous allez voir que la
frontière quand même extrêmement minces
d'un côté on a le psychopathe on sait
que ce type de personnalité n'a pas la
capacité vraiment d'aimer et d'établir
des relations avec les autres c'est
quelqu'un qui est très égocentrique en
général on retrouve ses caractéristiques
la froid et calculateur ne s'attache pas
aux gens manipulateur menteur et d'un
autre côté on va avoir le sociopathe qui
va avoir des caractéristiques similaires
mais avec quelques variantes on sait qu
un sociopathe a tendance à être plus
impulsifs par exemple que le psychopathe
les plus enclins à des gros accès de
rage de colère guilhem paillard brunet
psychiatre à lyon qui a bien voulu
répondre à mes questions explique que
psychopathe est sociopathe peuvent se
montrer tous les deux agressif mais pour
des raisons très différentes
le psychopathe serait agressif de
manière calculée en utilisant sa colère
de manière utilitaire pour obtenir
quelque chose mais sans la ressentir
fortement tandis que le sociopathe
ressentirai plus fortement la colère et
l'anxiété que la moyenne des gens
l'exprimant donc par impulsivité malgré
lui il a une tendance à surinterpréter
l'hostilité qu'ont les autres à son
égard vers quelqu'un qui répond pas
bonjour tout de suite il se dit qu'est
ce qui me vaut 8
au niveau des autres grandes différences
on à l'absence de conscience chez de
psychopathe alors je vais vous expliquer
ça un peu mieux ce dernier contrairement
aux sociopathe ne va généralement pas
considérer ces actions comme étant
mauvaise va pas connaître la culpabilité
alors qu un sociopathe pour à la
ressentir même si c'est pas beau coup en
prenant en compte par exemple qu'il ya
des degrés différents de psychopathie il
ya certaines personnes qui seront
mettront jamais en question et d'autres
qu'ils le feront comme on a pu voir avec
le chercheur qui à découvrir sa propre
psychopathie en regardant ces scans de
cerveau mais en anglais à cette grande
question
est-ce qu'on est ainsi ou est-ce qu'au
final on devient on aurait plutôt
tendance à penser qu'on les psychopathes
il ya une sorte de prédisposition
génétique alors que la sociopathie peut
être façonnées par son environnement
guilhem paliard brunet m'explique que
c'est une interaction entre
vulnérabilité génétique et un impact
environnemental
c'est les deux sociopathie et
psychopathe y aurait donc une
construction un peu différente le
psychopathe serait fortement déterminée
génétiquement mais du coup ça n'exclut
pas les causes environnementales alors
que le sociopathe en revanche se
construirait durant l'enfance avec une
forte forte composante environnementale
et certains facteurs de risque
négligence parentale abus violence
inconstance au niveau de l'éducation etc
il ya quand même une question
intéressante qui se pose c'est celle de
l'empathie qu on en avait parlé dans la
première vidéo de cette série et vous
avez longuement débattu avec moi en
commentaire et même pas un débat vous
m'avez apporté énormément de source chez
les psychopathes il y a un réel déficit
d'empathie en soit ça coule de source
mais il ya une nuance intéressante à
savoir les psychopathes ne peuvent pas
ressentir les émotions des autres leur
empathie affective 1 est fortement
affectée du coup à la première vidéo
j'avais fait un raccourci en disant
qu'il ne ressentait pas d'émotions en
fait ils en ressentent me recentre iront
jamais celle des autres en revanche ils
comprennent les émotions des autres ils
peuvent donc s'en servir pour les
manipuler leur empathie cognitive elle
est préservé et notre charte 6-4 nous
expliquent qu'ils peuvent donc percevoir
les émotions des autres sans en être
affecté personnellement les sociopathes
quant à eux au moins d'empathie que le
reste de la population en général mais
sont tout de même capables de ressentir
au fond d'eux donc ils n'ont pas la
capacité de faire du mal aux autres sans
rien ressentir d'ailleurs dans quelle
profession est ce qu'on retrouve le plus
de psychopathe au final puisque ce sont
des personnes généralement charismatique
avec du sang froid et une facilité de
prise de décision on va souvent les
retrouver dans des postes de leader pdg
avocat commercial chirurgien un
journaliste encore officier de police
président de république on s'est pas
lassé des hypothèses mais on peut la
retrouver dans ces hauts postes on le
retrouve donc rarement dans des métiers
beaucoup plus empathique comme un
fermier ou thérapeute par exemple et ça
ça nous amène au coeur du sujet les
criminels bien sûr tous les psychopathes
et les sociopathes ne sont pas des
tueurs mais lorsqu'il leçons ça donne
quoi vous avez peut-être déjà entendu
dire que les sociopathes sont souvent
plus instable que les psychopathes est
ce que c'est quelque chose d'avéré eh
bien oui et sociaux pas devons avoir
plus tendance à commettre des actes et
donc des crimes de façon impulsive et
désorganisés sans prendre en compte les
conséquences de leurs actions mais quand
même si copat commet un crime il est
généralement planifier de manière
méticuleuse céline est très il va faire
en sorte de pensée à tous les détails
pour éviter de se faire inculper les
psychopathes sont alors la plupart du
temps des tueurs en série c'est
difficile à repérer puisque d'extérieur
on peut les trouver tout à fait normaux
ces personnes là peut-être un peu froid
sans trop d'émotions mais rien
d'alarmant on peut prendre l'exemple
terrible de francis pot le tueur en
série tristement célèbre en l'oci
surnommé le routard du crime francis
heaulme a été reconnu coupable de onze
meurtres il a été décrit comme un
psychopathe à l'attitude froide lors des
assises de reims il serait donc les avec
ce trouble et son environnement familial
ne l'a certainement pas aidé puisque
dans son enfance il a vécu dans une
famille d'alcoolique il voyait son père
cogné sa mère un père qui ne donnait pas
d'affection francis sombre lui aussi
dans l'alcool dès l'âge de 16 ans il
commet des violences envers lui-même qui
vont de l'automutilation jusqu'aux
tentatives de suicide son avocat raconte
que son père lui mettais je cite des
raclées avec un air de bleus quand il
était petit et qui l'enfermé dans la
cave en le privant de nourriture et
c'est sa mère qui alors venez le
libérant douce pour lui donner un petit
peu de nourriture lorsque sa mère est
décédée il a commencé à se tourner vers
la folie criminelle qui l'a poussé à
tuer une première femme plus rapidement
d'autres personnes en plus de son
trouble les médecins lui aussi
diagnostiqué le syndrome de klinefelter
qui lui fait disposer d'un promozone
féminin supplémentaires et là vous allez
me dire fabien c'est quoi le rapport et
bien d'après des experts cette anomalie
génétique aurait contribué à rendre sa
personnalité encore plus confuse et
puisqu'elle était confuse si on mélange
ça à son autre pathologie de
psychopathie ça donnait ce cocktail
terrifiant alors même s'il a été décrit
comme étant un psychopathe est victime
d'une altération du discernement
il a quand même été reconnu responsable
de ses actes notre psychiatre nous
explique d'ailleurs que
psychopathe pouvant être froid et
calculateur il est difficile d'affirmer
qu'ils ne sont pas responsable des actes
qu'il commette mais est ce qu une
enfance heureuse et épanouie aurait fait
de francis heaulme un psychopathe sans
histoire un petit peu comme le chercheur
en neurosciences du début de cette vidéo
peut-être ça malheureusement on pourra
jamais le savoir du côté des sociopathes
on peut prendre l'exemple de brian
laudrup même si pour le moment cela
reste une théorie parce que c'est une
histoire qui est très très récente
l'américain brian laundry était en
voyage avec sa fiancée une influence
c'est ce qui s'appelle gaby betty tôt
jusqu'à ce que celle-ci se retrouvée
morte étranglée le comportement très
étrange de son fiancé à être tiré
l'attention de beaucoup de monde
puisqu'il s'est enfui juste après son
décès et finalement quelques semaines
plus tard il a été lui aussi retrouvé
mort d'après les analyses il se serait
suicidé est ce qu'il aurait commis lui
même ce terrible crime tout laisse à
penser que oui même si c'est pas encore
confirmée à ce jour du moins ça n'était
pas confirmée au moment nous avons
tourné cette vidéo met fin janvier le
fbi a publié l'intégralité du contenu du
carnet incluant les aveux de bryan qui
explique comment il a tué sa fiancée
fait troublant un journal intime a été
retrouvé près du jeune homme et on peut
y voir ses dessins sont des dessins
démoniaque avec des couteaux du sens
très glauque et en faisant des
investigations les chercheurs ont aussi
repéré le croquis d'une femme
ensanglantée qui était en train de
gier on dit comme ça un de gier sur le
sol pour horna gradnik une psychologue
et psychanalyste c'est bryan qui aurait
tué gamin mais est ce que le crime avait
été planifiée quoi qu'il en soit le
docteur qui a analysé la personnalité de
brian avance une théorie selon laquelle
il s'agirait bien d'un sociopathe en
expliquant qu'il sait comment jouer avec
les flics il sait comment être charmant
que des sociopathes sont doués pour
décrypter leur environnement ils ont une
certaine facilité quand même à créer une
ambiance qui décède à se sortir d'un
mauvais pas quant à son curieux journal
intime le docteur rural nick explique
que beaucoup de gens retranscrire leurs
émotions négatives par le biais d'
images violentes il peut aussi arriver
que des personnes en proie à diverses
maladies mentales sans quelque sorte
bombardés d'imagés violentes qui sont
des sortes de représentations de ce
qu'elles ressentent à l'intérieur mais
s'il ya quelque chose à retenir c'est
que les socios pad et les psychopathes
partagent tous les deux des
caractéristiques
commune toutefois la distinction entre
les deux est donc assez trouble encore
très débattue à ce jour des sociopathes
serait donc plus impulsifs est
imprévisible les psychopathes aurait
davantage de sang froid et serait
beaucoup plus que poser les psychopathes
ce rennais ainsi contrairement aux
sociopathe qui en gros le deviennent
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu vous
a intéressé c'est la nouvelle vidéo
d'une série qu'on est en train de créer
on a fait le premier épisode il ya très
longtemps le deuxième a tardé à venir
dites nous dans les commentaires si ça
vous passionne si vous voulez qui est
une suite on a déjà nous de notre côté
pas mal d'idées merci encore à north bay
peine d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
vous pouvez le télécharger en passant
par mon lien présent de la description
pour profiter de l'offre et moi de mon
côté si vous voulez me rencontrer
n'oubliez pas que je suis en tournée
actuellement jusqu'au mois de juin il
reste quelques vides où il reste des
places vous les avez qui s'affiche là
quelque part donc ce sont des petites
salles intimes manceaux à la fin on
discute c'est la création de mon nouveau
spectacle ça laboratoire
d'expérimentation c'est très cool aviv
si vous voulez venir quant à moi je
m'appelle toujours
policard
fabrication mais deux autres vidéos
l'une sur le premier épisode donc de
cette série là et une autre sur des bugs
un peu troublant qu'il existe dans le
cerveau vous pouvez vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube c'est gratuit pour fil
des ans tant que c'est gratuit est ce
que facebook restera gratuite sa vie à
priori oui ok me prenez soin de vous et
à très bientôt ciao